our second date she was like I just feel
like you're like a friend type of guy oh
friends yeah second date he hadn't
kissed me and I was like what the hell
and then I just gave like the most
sickening Belly Laugh of all time if you
know you told me you're like I actually
respect you and that was what it was I
was like I enjoy talking to you I don't
feel like I have to like pretend to wait
for you to stop talking so that I can
try and talk about something that I find
more interesting I just liked hanging I
was like I'm gonna be working here if
you want to meet me there and then she
would just work next to me and that was
what we did after like the first date